ich habe mich geärgert über jürgen klopp
ich weiß allein schon dieser satz bringt
einem keine sympathien ist jürgen klopp
doch so was wie das national idol der
nationalheilige jeder findet jürgen
klopp sympathisch was soll man
eigentlich auch gegen jürgen klopp habe
ich bin mir dessen bewusst und kann zu
einem stützung führen auch mir ist
jürgen klopp eigentlich sehr sympathisch
doch jetzt na ja es geht so denn er hat
gesagt über im verwall gerade spot hat
er auch genutzt er hat gesagt
dass im verwall gar ja eigentlich so ich
verstehe nicht warum ich möchte ihnen
nicht viel falsch zitieren jürgen klopp
hat gesagt ich verstehe nicht warum das
eine einschränkung der freiheit ist wenn
es so ist dann ist es verbot betrunken
zu fahren auch eine
freiheitseinschränkung
jürgen klopp ist meines verständnis wenn
ich dieses zitat leser also die impf
verweigerung die entscheidung sich nicht
impfen zu lassen genauso wie besoffen
auto zu fahren weil man damit die
allgemeinheit in gefahr bringt es ist
aber ein schwieriger standpunkt die ich
finde denn manche theologen wie zb
hendrik strikt sagen dass man als
geimpfter wie zb ich genau so eine hohe
viruslast im rachen haben kann hier ein
nicht geimpfter das heißt ich würde ja
als geimpfte genauso meine vier
anwesenden gäste heute ja gefährden wie
wenn ich nicht gibt wäre und deswegen
finde ich hier im klopft aussage sehr
schwierig vor allem glaube ich aber auch
aktuell ist es nicht so dass wir so eine
gute stimmung in der gesellschaft haben
unter 50 prozent trauen sich nicht mehr
ihre politische meinung zu sagen dass
man die gesellschaft noch mehr spalten
solche als mann zu ihr stand tut was ich
daran vor allem sehr verwunderlich
findet obwohl ich genau wie du
jugendclub sehr sympathisch finde und
auch höchsten respekt vor seiner
leistung als trainer habe und ihn als
menschen auch sehr schätze ist dass man
das auch nicht miteinander vergleichen
kann also wenn ich besoffen autofahrer
gefährlich andere menschen weil ich
unzurechnungsfähig bin also ich habe ja
auch eine sehr verzögert der
reaktionszeit das heißt ich kann nicht
so auto fahren wie ich es in nüchternem
zustand tun würde aber ein geimpft und
ein umkämpfter sind ja in ihrer
leistungsfähigkeit wenn man so will
nicht gleich also nicht uneingeschränkt
das muss man ja dazu sagen und was sich
daran noch ebenso verwunderlich finde
und da hat sich jürgen klopp eigentor
geschossen ist dass er am 4 märz 2020
als diese ganze impf debatte los ging
und das krone virus losging wurden
natürlich alle trainer alle sportler
befragt was sie denn zu dieser impf
debatte sagen würden also nahe bei
sportler ja auch vor einer potenziellen
impfpflicht standen aufgrund der
anstehenden europameisterschaft und so
weiter und so fort und damals sagte
jürgen klopp es ist völlig egal was
prominente leute dazu sagen experten
sollten über das corona virus reden und
den leuten sagen was sie tun sollen
meine meinung zu corona ist unwichtig
das hat dann noch genau das hat er ja
noch am 4 märz 2020 gesagt man hier auch
in person der aussagen
damit schießt man sich ja auch ein
eigentor muss man ja leider sagen obwohl
jürgen klopp eigentlich sehr viele
treffer erzielt aber in dem fall hat er
sich ein eigenes eingeschlossen damals
glaube ich grundsätzlich verstehen dass
ungeimpfte sich selbst gefährden und
andere ungeimpfte jedenfalls im
wesentlichen weil die geimpften eben
nicht mehr angesteckt werden können im
regelfall da gibt es ausnahmen fall im
regelfall aber ja also die sind sich
selbst und den anderen gegenüber
schädlich die sich so verhalten wie sie
selber und
ich glaube wir haben inzwischen einen
eine situation erreicht wo solche
aufforderungen nur noch trotz auslösen
sie verfestigen also die ablehnung des
impfens weil viele ungeimpfte die meint
der meinung sind hat gibt es irgendeine
große starts verschwörung wo alle die
ihren namen haben eingebunden sind und
ihnen weismachen wollen sie müssen sich
unbedingt impfen lassen das tun wir
jetzt erst recht nicht es hilft nix aber
wir machen die fehler die wir machen
einen fehler indem wir diese menschen
die sorgen haben sie eben zu lassen alle
quasi in eine ecke stellen grünen nicht
als querdenker und dergleichen aber
sagen naja die verstehen da irgendwas
nicht ich habe gerade gestern
tatsächlich mit mit sehr wirklich
wenig sagen gebildeten sind sie auch
aber das klingt so doof also auf jeden
fall menschen die die sich intensiv mit
dieser materie befassen eine diskussion
darüber gehabt auch die hatten
vorbehalte auch witziger weise durchs
netz genährt man sagt hier ja wie ist
das aber der kern geht eher dahin was
viele viele menschen hier auch sich
intensiv damit befassen ja fragt
verändert dass in irgendeiner
weise das erbgut nicht weil es ja
potenziell bei bestimmten impfstoffen
auch tod
unwesentlich sagen diejenigen diese eben
punkt verabreichen bei anderen biotech
und so entsprechend nicht aber das ist
ja der kern von diejenigen die sich
intensiv damit befassen und jetzt so
eine reine zweig regel zu machen sie
sagen okay entweder geimpft oder eben
gelesen das ist das einzige was zählt
das ist nicht fair ja aber wir haben gar
ein taviani dagegen satz ich stimme dir
vollkommen zu es gibt jeder der sich so
in der gesellschaft bewegt in seinem
eigenen umfeld trifft doch immer wieder
auf menschen die es nicht tun selbst in
die eigene verwandtschaft der ich sage
das mit dem trotz nicht ohne hintergrund
die verhärten sich immer mehr wenn sie
so was hören sie haben angefangen mit
berechtigten sorgen sollen wir überhaupt
und so weiter viele die in der ddr
aufgewachsen sind übrigens und sich
impfen lassen mussten da gab es gar
keinen kommen ganz andere mentalität
sind aber heute auf der ganzen welt und
sagen damals mussten wir heute machen
wir das nicht mehr so da gibt es diverse
motive das ist mir völlig wurscht
welches motiv jemand hat dann lässt das
eben nicht impfen und wandelt ist eben
erkrankt
der punkt stimmt jetzt alle miteinander
zu ich mir dem nicht unbedingt
widersprechen der punkt ist doch wie
schaffen wir es denn dann überhaupt noch
mehr menschen davon zu überzeugen sich
impfen zu lassen klar findet findet
verdruss dadurch statt dass wir dieses
im jogging betreibe ich würde es nicht
als impf mobbing bezeichnen weil ich
trotzdem finde man muss auch mal ein
finger in die wunde legen und sagen alle
müssen sich impfen lassen damit welche
rauskommen aus der pandemie nicht alle
aber diese herdenimmunität brauchen wir
aber wie schaffen wir es alle menschen
irgendwie davon zu überzeugen dass es
wichtig ist sah sich impfen lassen
können wenn ich dir da entgegnen darf es
geht ja also warum wir uns ja impfen
sollen ist um uns und unsere mitmenschen
zu schützen richtig und so wie nina das
ja erklärt hat ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken als
geimpfter genauso hoch wie die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein negativer
test falsch ist das heißt das ziel von
diesem ganzen disput ist ja das sind wir
uns und unsere mitmenschen vor dem
corona virus schützen nehmen wir das
beispiel restaurants 2g oder 3g ob ich
jetzt ins restaurant geht und negativ
nachweis ich getestet bin oder geimpft
ist ja dann im endeffekt das gleiche ich
schütze mich als negativ getestet und
meine mitmenschen genauso wie ich meine
mitmenschen und mich als geimpfter
schützt was den schrägen weiter von mir
du trägst als geimpfter laut strikt
sollte er recht haben das weiß ich nicht
aber du trägst als geimpfte genauso wie
ihre viruslast jetzt nicht geben das
heißt du kannst genauso anschauen und
ich habe einen fenster in der dritten
liga aktiv ist geimpft weil im fußball
ist es gang und gäbe und da sind auch
würde ich jetzt mal behaupten ich kenne
den genauen zahlen nicht aber sind auch
sehr viele spieler funktionäre und so
weiter geimpft aufgrund der sportart
klar und in dem umkreis in dem sie sich
bewegen und der ist geimpft und hat sich
mit dem corona virus angesteckt na klar
ist es möglich der punkt der impfung ist
ja nicht alleine dass man die infektion
nicht weiter tragen kann weil das steht
außer frage wir wissen dass
wissenschaftlich bewiesen du kannst es
machen der punkt ist dass ich dazu
beitrage dass deutlich weniger
infektionen stattfindet dass es bei
gedankt und das über eine erhöhte und
nicht nur das man selber nicht unter
sondern dass der verlauf wird ich bin
ich bin heute 3g ich bin im märz
erkrankt ich bin jetzt geimpft ich bin
aber zusätzlich auch getestet so ist
nicht cool corona zu haben und ich
glaube mit der impfung hätte es entweder
nicht bekommen oder einfach nur
schwächeren verlauf gehabt und darauf
hinzuarbeiten dass den menschen zu
vermitteln zu sagen es hilft euch
tatsächlich und ich meine wir haben die
masern impfpflicht warum haben wir sie
werden nämlich nicht fürs restaurant und
nicht nehmen hoch nämlich ist aber
wollen die macher nicht eingriff er wird
damit nicht auf jedes kind in der kita
sich ansteckt manche kinder eben nicht
nur für digital warum sie überall der
punkte wohl ganz einfach die resistenz
die man gegen einen impfstoff haben kann
davor andere zu schützen ihnen
möglicherweise gutes zu tun
möglicherweise zu verhindern dass sie
sich anstecken und all das kann eine
impfung bewirkt da müssen wir hinkommen
was mich stört daran ist dass es hier
jetzt wieder über den fussball tendenzen
gibt die leute auszuschliessen die eben
sagen ich lasse mich nicht impfen bin
aber bereit nicht testen zu lassen und
wie wird diese zweig regelung eingeführt
wird offenbar da auch in liverpool und
gesagt entweder getestet oder gelesen
aber wer hier nichts von beidem ist
kommt hier gar nicht rein das ist nicht
fair bin haben wir gleich
es muss genau zugang haben auch zu den
stadion oder zu anderen einrichten
[Musik]